das ressour von Außenministerin Berber
hat jetzt ein Entwurf zur feministischer
Außenpolitiker arbeitet in diesem zwölf
punkte-programm ist auch die
Arbeitsweise im Auswärtigen Dienst
geregelt dabei geht es um mehr als nur
um eine gendergerechte Sprache es geht
auch um eine entsprechende Arbeitsweise
der Spiegel der zitiert aus dem Papier
folgendes die Botschafterin wird für das
Mainstreaming feministischer
Außenpolitik Sorge tragen also sprich es
geht um ein Geldtopf der soll dann
verteilt werden für Gender Gerechtigkeit
dass ein Thema jetzt bei 8:15 Uhr wir
fahren heute eine Botschafter in für
feministische Außenpolitik ist das etwas
auf dass sie schon immer gewartet haben
wirklich nicht darauf habe ich niemand
gewartet ähm halte das für so eine
ähnliche
Schnaps Nummer wie
360 Grad Drehung die sie von Putin
verlangt hat oder wie die
Außenministerin Alleingang ja aus
Russland den Krieg erklärt hat und aus
dem Wahlkampf wissen ja auch schon was
mein Thema betrifft sie meinte ja die
Energiekrise mit der mit
tiefkühlhähnchen bekämpfen zu können die
man dann auf und abkühlen kann ich denke
wir haben ganz andere Probleme in
Deutschland also dass wir uns auf solche
irratischen
Politik peruierten
eindrehen müssen es kotzt einfach nur
ein bisschen mehr Geld ja mehr Geld aber
wir haben mal weiter reingelesen was in
diesem Entwurf steht der Spiegel sagt da
drin steht feministische Außenpolitik
hält keine Zauberformel bereit mit der
sich unmittelbare sicherheitspolitische
Bedrohungen bewältigen lassen also diese
Einsicht steht da drin hereinbird das
heißt feministische Außenpolitik wird
also weiter auch auf militärische Stärke
setzen setzen müssen beruhigt sie das
nein überhaupt nicht letzten Endes ich
sehe da keinen Unterschied zwischen den
sexes ich meine in der Politik zumindest
und es gibt jetzt gerade ein Film bei
der Berlinale habe ich vernommen wo
guldame hier als eben dort
von einer Schauspielerin dargestellt
wird es geht um den sechs Tage Krieg und
schon damals gab es in bestimmten Länder
Frauen die Politik gemacht haben und gut
gemacht haben und man kann nicht 50
Prozent der Bevölkerung irgendwie
benachteiligen
ausschließen aber jetzt kommt das aber
ich bin der Meinung dass nicht eben
gender entscheiden soll sondern ich
Qualifikation und ich kenne also
viele Frauen im Business die sagen das
haben wir es nicht gerne wir wollen
irgendwie in den Vorstand oder in sie in
die Geschäftsführung rein weil wir so
qualifiziert sind und nicht weil wir
eben hier ein eine Position ausfüllen
müssen Qualifikation soll entscheiden
erbarme sie waren auch bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz jetzt spürt man da
schon etwas von einem frischen
feministischen Wind ist Außenpolitik
vielleicht auch zu männlich geprägt gibt
es da einen Punkt in sie erkennen ja es
sind sehr viele Frauen anwesend allein
deswegen schon dieses eine berühmte Bild
mit den ja knapp 30 SEOs ohne Frau als
nicht mehr gegeben
aber mein Ende ist wichtig was dabei
rauskommt wenn jetzt durch feministische
Außenpolitik endlich mal nationale
Interessen benannt werden
Sicherheitsinteressen nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch Europas dann
wäre das gut aber wir tun und schwer
damit wir können weder eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie vorlegen die ja
angeblich fertig hätte sein sollen in
München noch kriegen wir eine Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat hin also diese
Ministerien Kochen weiterhin ihr
Süppchen sei es jetzt masochistisch oder
feministisch oder was auch immer mir ist
es egal wie das Ganze betitelt wird es
sollte was dabei rauskommen dass dafür
sorgt dass wir weiterhin in Sicherheit
und im Wohlstand leben können also das
Ganze mehr auf eine Sachebene wieder
runterholen bin mir Nessler gerade in
Behörden hat man manchmal das Gefühl der
würde doch so ein frischer Wind eine
frische Ideen frische Ansatz ganz gut
tun das ist richtig wir brauchen glaube
ich frische Ansätze überall aber ich
glaube es ist das was die Kollegen auch
schon gesagt haben es kommt auf die
Inhalte an wir brauchen was Frisches das
muss aber auch effektiv sein es muss
vernünftig sein es muss überlegt sein
und einfach nur ein frisches Etikett
drauf kleben sozusagen feministische
Außenpolitik zum Beispiel das reicht
nicht wir brauchen eine gute vernünftige
Politik Außenpolitik und wie wir die
dann nennen ist im Endeffekt egal wir
müssen auf jeden Fall sprechen hier in
dieser Runde auch über die Rede der
Nation von der Vladimir Putin Weinberg
war das in etwa die Rede die sie auch
erwartet hatten
also putin ist immer gut für eine
Überraschung das ist keine Frage und
ja das war eine hurra rede also für mich
war natürlich sehr interessant dass es
ein narrativ geändert hat weil
es ist erstmal wir machen dieses Special
Operation und dachte in drei Tagen ist
er in Kiel und wird dort mit den
Fähnchen begrüßt und sein narrativer
erstmal er will die Ukraine von
Faschismus und Nationalismus befreien
und jetzt redet der plötzlich ganz ist
das mal groß kotzig über den Kampf gegen
den Westen gegen Amerika gegen den die
verweichung des Westens der schlechten
attituts die wir im Westen haben großen
Teil natürlich auch im gegen Gender und
ähm Homosexualität und eine solche
Sachen und
unterscheiden sich jetzt hier als der
große Moralist der alten Kultur
darstellen und ich fand dieser rede ich
habe mir die also bei CNN angeguckt also
mit dem Original Übersetzung in Englisch
und da waren natürlich viele Punkte die
mich sehr geärgert haben vor allem null
Interesse an einer Lösung an eine
an einem peace an einem Verhandlung
hat nur hurra hurra und wir sind die
größten wir schaffen es und also hat
gelogen im Sinne der alten Sowjets wie
das immer früher war und im Grunde
nichts Neues beigebracht und sie sagen
ja jetzt auch ganz klar da müssen wir
stark zusammenhalten da müssen wir stark
dagegen halten und das das klappt auch
nur mit einem starken vereinten Westen
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie